you don't need any sunblock you can let
yourself just get out never use sunblock
dude yeah you got that you don't wear
any of that stuff no i don't know he's a
little he's literally
neither do the kid well my boston is
pretty white but tiger neither no
something
you wear
i don't tamper if you went to the
dermatologist you get skin tight yeah of
course you know all right i had a skin a
little bit he was like you know on the
beach together where's the hat
remember
itching on my back right do you remember
this right
so somebody said right back so i go
whatever and the guy takes it off yeah
and then they send us a lab is the thing
i get a call from the nurse she goes you
got some cancer there i go what she goes
you have a squamous cell i go whoa now i
didn't know that then this is the nurse
i didn't know that it was a little skin
thing that doesn't spread
she said you got to stay out of the sun
you got to put some block everywhere and
i go well for how long should well the
rest of your life yeah you know i go
so
i see him i don't know if you remember
this
i'm literally in long sleeves
and i have a hat on and sunglasses
huge hats on no the podcast i'm waiting
like this and i'm in the shade and he
goes what are you doing here he's like
that for me i have cancer hypochondria i
have cancer
dude i was so [ __ ] up for the longest
time now though i have to go get checked
all the time but nothing
is crazy you doing you're doing good i
get [ __ ] taken off i'm like what is this
and the dermatologist there's nothing
there yeah you're paying the rest so
it's if it's a cancer but it just
doesn't spread well you don't want to
[ __ ] around you got to go once a year
especially when you're older you don't
need to go no it's when you have my skin
oh my shitty skin that's not built for
the sun if you have a lot of melanin
and here's the other thing with with
what they think
how you eat actually has a factor in
in skin cancer so
you know crazy
no i eat well but i'm saying as a kid
you got to remember i grew up in [ __ ]
tropical i grew up in the sun and you
weren't eating [ __ ] no but i did
really well but in the 70s old old pinky
boy over here was in the sun all the
time i never did you wouldn't like
schultzy's wedding because it's all sun
awesome also
all sun looked like montecito it was
great small wedding yeah it was great
moving too right you said not well what
do you mean oh yeah his
his speech was insane dude yeah yeah
he's a great i'll see the boy right yeah
his speeches it's just yeah it's tough
because uh
i gotta ask you it's tough because his
you know his dad has als and doesn't i
didn't know that yeah
so he was like he was like you know one
thing about you know me you know i
wouldn't be anything without my dad and
his dad's right there you know it's
tough i didn't know that that's tough
the als is a terrible disease man tough
man it's where you just there was a dry
eye in the room there was a i mean dude
and he was crying he's like how old is
his dad i don't you know two young daddy
how old are you two young people
shut up there you go
als alex
yeah because your body what happens is
your body you literally lose all muscle
function damn yeah just for him for him
it messes up his memory too like he
doesn't
like uh schultzy sold out radio uh city
music hall in new york which is a big
deal his name's on the bill he saw like
six shows wow and he called his dad to
tell him and i was like okay and then
forgot yeah this dad was walking down
the street to get stuff and saw and took
pictures like look at this look what i
saw yeah dad we talked about it yeah
my grandfather had that on my dad's side
my grandfather would look at me and like
start and i was young and i'd get scared
he'd go pat what are you doing right now
i was like i'm not panicking my dad he
thinks you're he thinks you're his son
just just just go with it just answer it
i would go with it i'd be like uh how
you doing you know it's just it was yeah
it was hard great wedding though they
did it right there was no like
it wasn't like super formal there's no
groomsmen or bridesmaids oh they just
knocked it out can i may i ask you a
question yes
it's really an honest question yes can
you go back to that picture
why do you always do that what you don't
look like you're smiling you look like
you're going
so i smiled no you don't that's no
that's how i smile you don't bubba you
smile like that you look like you're
like
can you knock out a little drinks there
it's really interesting almost all your
pictures you have a [ __ ] really hard
grimace yeah i'm having to get time
though okay you think this is true i
don't in that picture i don't believe
that and that's not a great deal you
look like something
schultzy was pretty emotional that's
right after he's pretty emotional yeah
he's a beautiful guy god that house
though jesus christ man is that what is
that
it's his wife's uh parents house they
just had it
built jesus christ
they're not giving away in montecito no
that's that's what you go money does by
happiness right there look at this this
is
uh right outside santa barbara
charlemagne charlemagne wow
you'll see uh he must be a cool guy yeah
surely it's great to see rogan
wow the whole
squad i've never seen schultzy so
nervous in my life man
he was nervous you know it's it's it's a
big deal in your life dude yeah when i
when my ex
uh met lex friedman for the first time
we hit off right away yeah he's great
he's a great guy smart individual oh
dude he why because he came up with the
driving technology for a company called
tesla because he's an mit professor and
a black belt and judo and jiu jitsu and
he's the lead of like robotics in
america god damn yeah we took this
picture and we took a million i mean his
eyes were like dude you guys are he was
i just [ __ ] posted all right dude
wait that's a good smile right there
that's not like that's not like it's
better the sun's in your eyes yeah that
sound was tough joe's head look like
looks like like mine
your head starts to die
right head yeah that's a that's a that's
a strong head i'm shrek i'm bigger than
everybody i'm sure you're a big kid
charlemagne's small too man is he yeah
little guy
yeah not big did you did you get that
suit last minute or you had that no
that's the best thing about whitney
looks like a cut out there like working
it's like a out like working for bravo
and e i have so many freaking things oh
yeah so many that's the best part about
working for them because because i'm so
big they're like no one can wear that
just keep it so like 40 seconds oh yeah
because they have the probably customers
yeah they're like just [ __ ] keep it
yeah yeah that's hilarious and then
rogan was showing me the uh
his club's gonna open next year you show
me the renderings of it jesus christ
it's nice huh dude everybody out there
is [ __ ] really it's it's
i've never seen anything like it wow
nuts everybody's what the rest of clubs
are [ __ ] oh god they're not gonna
compete nuts real going against it oh so
stupid
it's crazy amazing well all right yeah
crazy because there are a lot of clubs
now in austin
not like this one we do see it not even
close and the money's put into it and
the staff and his lineups it's gonna be
tough mm-hmm it's gonna be tough it was
so crazy that's great yeah it's gonna be
dope good for him that's gonna be really
dope awesome yeah like's a smart
individual dude weddings i try at
weddings i get i get very important i
usually don't that one i did it's just
schultzy he was super emotional he's
talking about his dad
i cried i cried um
like a couple things i i've cried at
like my sister's wedding i cried my own
wedding i didn't cry but i it was very
important to me that i speak to my
parents
and the people i love it was like a
moment to say if i die tomorrow just
know that this is how i feel about all
of you yeah i was not ready for schultzy
and then yeah there was in a draw i'm
telling everybody cried you know what i
cried at tar i didn't even know tark
well but he invited me to his wedding
yeah we were both there but i know and
when when uh when they started talking
about his dad
and he started kind of tear up yeah and
his his dad's brother came behind him
yeah because dad passed away yeah dude i
was it was just you see this [ __ ]
warrior this man anytime someone talks
about their dad or their kids yeah it is
emotional yeah he did it right though
had open bar at some of the best whiskey
i'll have it in here it's called johnny
drum uh bourbon [ __ ] it was nice really
we all
you
got
really we all got something that's well
you supposed to smash it was nice open
bar and then they had like food trucks
like wood fire pizza sushi
taco street tacos it was dope that's
beautiful it was dope they stayed later
because
i stayed in ojai so i had to get back
with the kiddos all right so i left
before they got you stayed at the ohio
valley and yeah yeah it was nice i got
married there how great is that [ __ ]
place
no i was doing our thing
it was it's really nice up there yeah
it's so nice up there yeah that's north
uh so if santa barbara's here yeah it's
it'd be nice no okay so i got married
and i decided for like 50 minute drive
from you know how long my you know the
vows where you're up there and the guys
makes this was yours a religious thing
no it wasn't it was under a tree at
valley valley and i know it's true
you're talking about with the lights on
it and i was like you know the one thing
people don't like at weddings is having
to sit there while people read hymns and
poems there's nothing worse there's
nothing worse right nobody got made six
hours that's right so i got married
that's that's obnoxious so the
walking down the aisle
i present you man and wife that lasted
for exactly i believe somebody timed it
12 minutes and no it was less it was it
was 11 minutes and 50 seconds
totally shultzy did the same thing like
there's no there's no sitting or
anything they came out that's part of it
they're like everybody get on the deck
they walked out everyone cheered they
both did their vows that's it that's it
my buddy he's like let's go eat open
bars yes we just went it was a small
wedding brian he it was you know i know
so many people and
yeah there was 200 people 200 people but
it was pretty nice it was fun
it was all my closest friends it was one
of the best times i've ever had in my
life it was like a time when i had such
a sick community i had such an
incredible community in la i can't even
tell you because all of us were young
and all of us were that dreams
aspirations yeah like like we were all
kind of just some people hadn't become
famous somebody everybody was kind of on
the comeback yeah it was the comments
that's cool it is
yours was small too yeah no one had we
didn't do a traditional wedding we just
got made at the courthouse and had a
party at the house oh but after going to
schulte's i'm like i looked at my girl
i'm like god you probably need something
like that she's like i would love this
yeah we'll figure it out yeah yeah
it'd be down it was cool yeah you and i
aren't the most sentimental about that
kind of stuff for my kids it might be
good it'd be cool it'd be cool i'd be
i'd be open for i think especially the
way he did like there was no best man
there's no did you guys do vows and
stuff though no like in the question you
just go to the courthouse oh you
literally just go in oh [ __ ] yeah
and then you just go to the courthouse
and then some you know random
yeah state like
no they just read a little something you
repeat it and then get your license oh
you got to have like a witness there
though oh yeah state official uh her
brother was over i did that i did that
too i did that first some people do that
and then they
get that's what i did
i got legally married for you know taxes
and benefits all that stuff yeah then
well yeah i remember the last time i've
been to a wedding
i don't really go to them
i don't know that weddings would happen
if it wasn't for women in the
relationship a lot of times guys are
like you know i'm usually yeah i usually
i usually frown upon weddings but
schultz he's really i mean really nailed
it man it's easy it was fun it's more
like a party
he's had it wasn't huge
i don't think there's a hundred people
there man that's great yeah it was
better it was dope
whittled it down to the people that you
really only care about montecito though
they're not giving that way huh the
neighbors are like ellen and [ __ ]
prince harry oh dude it's nuts kidding
me
oh no it might be the best place in the
world
it's great i mean there's nothing out
there
it's so beautiful but yeah peaceful for
sure
yeah i might go crazy but it's pretty
amazing yeah and yeah it'd be tough as a
comic that's the question of drive like
yeah you know it's hour drive at least
how's drive to l.a what do you like i
don't know like how the view is
beautiful that comfort but how long
until you got a little a little restless
i would be fine i'm a homebody like give
me a dope house i don't need anything
yeah and if uh postmates goes out there
i'm good right i don't go out at night
i'm not trucking and driving i'm good
that's ideal for me yeah it's just too
far if you're trying to do sets or
you know if you like if you have to
drive into the west side for a meeting
or something like you're talking about
[ __ ]
three hours out of your day yeah yeah
i'll never leave leave where i am now
like where you're at the best place yeah
it's nice out there all my life yeah
yeah view of the ocean but um
i'm saying wait i love l.a man i don't
know a lot of people talk [ __ ] on him
i [ __ ] like no you know what by the
way
and we know some people who are leaving
our boy josh wolfe is now leaving
nashville and there are a lot of people
that are leaving certain areas that were
really popular to go to it's like la is
much better what you pay for but i think
a lot of it during the pandemic people
freaked out [ __ ] i almost did too and i
was looking at property in nashville and
austin wasn't yet yeah i looked at both
yeah i looked at bull i flew out there
was my girl yeah
i got serious about it that's but it was
the high like you don't make any
irrational decisions i think a lot of
guys did now they're like
and like buying a house and then sell it
within a year not making money really no
no you're not and everybody bought when
it was going up because those prices
went they jacked up by the [ __ ] day
oh yeah by the day the meeting now uh
really everywhere yeah
nashville and austin but where but uh
josh has moved from nashville to vegas
yeah yeah he's going to vegas yeah i
know a lot of people are pretty happy
with vegas penny
yeah
i think it's a tough one
uh both of them tough
i think the least vegas is closer to
yeah it is yeah i'll stay i i'm scared
i'm stick nelly yeah
yeah unless just [ __ ] totally hits the
fan they lock us back down i'm not
leaving right
right
it's interesting well you know i don't
know if you've seen this but san
francisco the mayor of san francisco i
mean san francisco has open air drug
markets and brazen robberies literally
everybody at the party she was at a
party 95 of the people she did a poll
had been a victim of crime had been a
victim of their car being broken into uh
uh the district attorney
went to
get in his car the district attorney has
been letting everybody out not
prosecuting anybody
and the motherfucker's car was broken
okay exactly well he's a [ __ ] they're
all but now they're backtracking like we
need more cars well london breed goes
the [ __ ]
in the present the [ __ ] is over she
went hard
she goes she grew up poor and so did new
york housing both were like this ain't
this stuff on the police ain't working
[ __ ] you like then now they're hiring
more police what a surprise and they
were like we're gonna start putting you
in jail instead of like letting you out
letting you out yeah yeah get the people
watching because they let them out
one is it's a sanctuary city so you're
not allowed to check somebody's
immigration status so you've got ms-13
ms-13 do the all over
the tenderloin they control the entire
drug trade they kill people they
intimidate people they rob people they
do everything ms-13 yeah straight-up
gangsters you're not allowed to check
their immigration status you you arrest
them for things they they organize these
uh property crimes under a thousand
dollars they have a calculator while
they're doing it
and no they they're out the next day and
when they're when they go to jail for
three hours the somebody takes their
place in the corner anyway like i've
talked to police officers there who it's
it's literally an open-air drug market
and she was like you got kids having to
get in the street because people are
using on the sidewalk what the [ __ ] and
their [ __ ] but she also said she's like
we've turned the city into [ __ ] like
this is going to stop yeah illegal
vending
disaster it's like south side chicago
it's like
you can throw the lump you need jail
dude how about that sometimes yeah bad
guys got to go yeah yeah how was uh kc
buddy it was great was i loved it was it
cold out there no no you know how about
this for christmas it's supposed to be
62 degrees
in in kansas city so unheard of i guess
global warming is a thing
like yes i don't know i mean either way
it was it was it got really cold one day
and then it was 60 then on sunday you
didn't try any barbecue or nothing i
didn't
i didn't i think it's just you don't
really go out of your way barbecue out
there
yeah i think that's the big one
it's at the gas station i think right
no it's got its own little spot um
right there i stay at the crossroads
which i really like is a hotel so i had
everything i needed
there it is barbecue's like the
well-known one author bryant's i've been
to
never been to danny edwards i found some
great restaurants though you did yeah
people think that joe's barbecue is like
right up there with like
there's another spot there's another
spot they have out there that's supposed
to be like
top-notch barbecue as well but it's just
tough if you eat the day of so much
sugar it's so healthy
239 that was the other one
we're talking about yeah it gets to you
yeah so um [ __ ] your pants
a little bit a little bit daddy had a
little bit of a cold
daddy had a little cold um what if you
guys well you and i both had you and i
didn't we don't admit it when we have it
it's like i got allergies but obviously
i have allergies yeah yeah which i do
but not in the winter brendan right
yeah well
for the longest time i'll be like i'm
fine i got a little scratchy thing and
then usually i beat it this one they
went from chest cold to then to the head
cold and i was like oh there's no way
i'm making this wedding yeah and then my
freaking uh housekeeper who straight
from mexico was like in her broken
english was like oh i have medicine i'm
like okay cool she comes over the next
day with a [ __ ] syringe full of
antibiotics she's like pull your pants
down what i was like what you got you
know i mean i like to roll the dice yeah
she goes whenever i'm sick i use this
and i'm in my head i'm like this would
be some weird [ __ ] i [ __ ] you not by
that night everything's gone everything
she put it in your ass oh yeah yeah and
then gave me pills
after like you had a straight up
antibiotic yeah i think it was just a
liquid z-pack because because for if
it's around for two weeks something's
going on there yes so
she gave me that i'm saying
fine well i'm a girl's sick she's she
got it and now she's that's tough do you
have a little coffee cough or did you
just so it started with a cough for
literally two weeks on top of that and i
had to sleep in another bedroom that's
how she is yeah yeah i i had to sleep in
another bedroom because he had sniffles
now you might have had i'm going to say
it out loud cobin you might have had the
omnicron no i got tested for it yeah i
did too but you might have had the omnic
oh you're that guy i know people i know
people now who've had the omnicron
variant really yeah but it's like real
quick and like it's more mild yeah super
mild right let's not shut the world down
no yeah i wish you know what i wish
they'd said about what do you want i'm
pro-vaccine okay no problem but i wish
they'd said this about the vaccine i
wish they'd said look
take the vaccine take the booster you're
gonna it's not gonna stop you from
getting coveted
but when you get it it'll make the
symptoms way less severe
which is a fact no they don't they
didn't say that and then they act like
you're straight up and you're immune and
that boosters are like well to be really
vaccinating you need boosters but you've
got to put them honest and rogan had a
doctor on a show like we actually have
hardcore evidence where if you've had
covert you cannot get it again wow like
it like that's why i heard immunity no
one wants to talk about it but people
that like the people getting sick are
people
that didn't get it got vaccinated now
they have the whatever it's called
variant you know the delta
the heavy evidence shows once people
have had the actual covet the original
strain they cannot get it again wow so
no one's getting it twice well i look
that up listen according to this doctor
who's pretty smart well i looked it up
the cdc said um there's no conclusive
proof yeah there's been no evidence that
people have got a choice and and but
everybody says you can get it three or
four times and everybody says uh my
friend caught it i know that show me
this doctor was saying it's like chicken
dogs once you get it you can't get it
again well now i don't know and that
might be misinformation i'm just saying
from a high level doctor that who's on
rogan yeah
so my friend my friend uh had the
booster well i've i know three people
well my sister and my
i know some people who had the booster
the shots uh they got covered yeah and
now now one is one of my friends got
real sick and the other one's fine the
the other the other people were i mean
it was tough but yeah just for two days
but it was this was their first time
getting it
yes yes i do think for sure the vaccine
will make your symptoms way less strong
than they could be but just let's be
honest about it yes we just need that
pill to come out
yeah what is that what is that supposed
to be supposed to be soon
yeah you say oh yeah they say england
already has it or something england has
it and that's not dude they're doing
those anti-whatever
uh pills in florida
i saw this black guy he's kind of a jack
black guy and he's and he's getting on
the plane and i swear to god we're in
kansas city and he's just got a mask and
it's it's so mesh
that i can see his whole face i can see
his mouth no he says no no no he's he's
just sitting like that and
he walks on and the flight is going to
go sir you have to have a different mask
he goes what because you have to have
masculine i'm covering my mouth she goes
so i can see
i called out it's like it's so hilarious
oh yeah well i told you i got the post
office thinking hey man you get some big
black guy big fat black guy you're
hitting me in your mask because i
[ __ ] grabbed the envelope goes like
this
and i was just like this better than the
guy's like i get what do you need man
yeah by the way
i got this this is from scott uh hussing
uh echo and ramadi first-hand story of
use from us marines in iraq's deadliest
city and um he gave this to me forward
by major general james livingston let me
see it you know a medal of honor
firsthand story of the u.s military in
ireland
oh damn
okay it's personalized yep
and i think you [ __ ] up because this
says for joe rogan
thanks for always supporting our veteran
tribe i know sharing the great stories
they need to be heard keep up the fire
brother semper fi
i gave you the robber
that's frustrating
can you please give me the one that was
i'd like to see the message was meant
for me
i'll take that back and bring me the
real one i have that on my ass i won't
be sending this to joe because he was
not gonna read it he gets fifty thousand
books he might there's
his office he's got like thousands of
gifts a thousand books yeah
uh
for joe wrote buddy thanks man
joe rogan's copying i'll say yeah
yeah send rogue in mine
echo and ramadi i think he's a best
seller
i'd read that for sure i went to the
[ __ ] dentist dude oh i gotta go
that's right man i went in for my
cleaning guess what what cavity oh shoot
where at uh no actually one one of my
fillings have fell out one at the bottom
did they fix them yeah did it hurt yeah
the cavity [ __ ] they gave you the
shots cuz i've had like a root root
canal and that [ __ ] didn't hurt at all i
got to feel nothing really you just
opposite but the but the when he was
like drilling
yes dude he goes he goes raise your hand
if there's pain dude i had to keep
raising my hand and would he give you
more shots like no he wouldn't give
yeah he did give me that the shots and
stuff like that but like he didn't
because usually when they get usually
when they give you the shots they're
supposed to let that [ __ ] sink in and
like wait for it yeah he went right
forward i was like bro let me [ __ ]
they check your gum health too because
you can get plaque below the gum line
which causes problems yeah he was like
he goes how's your blood pressure i was
like i'm [ __ ] high right now mine's
not right he was like doing his little
thing with it and then he's like bro
what was the last time
we've been over there i don't know you
guys got to go just get it done i'm just
feel better i can't eat sweets every one
of my dudes i've had sugar in four weeks
do you know me on my [ __ ] sugar that
hurts yeah if i eat sugar it hurts my
teeth well you've got a cavity no i know
you gotta get
your boy losing weight
chipped my [ __ ] crown so i had to go
in there hey quick question since you're
just there can they just put gold teeth
over my hand instead of drilling wait no
do they have to drill and then tap it
yes bob yeah
what they have to do no so they won't
they'll shave that yeah and then put the
gold fronts on yeah the shaving doesn't
really hurt it's the [ __ ] drill i
just want the drilling can i just put a
goal really so he was doing it
here's what they do they're going to
take care of how you know hold on
they're going to have to because i've
been dead as many times what they got to
do now 9 years
you got some bacteria and you got some
decay so what we got to do i'm sure
using the nicotine we got to get the old
we got to get the decay out of there now
that's there's a drill we got to do no
that's where they scrape scraper that's
what they spread yeah my teeth are soft
we got to get deep in there i'm sorry
now you got nerves so what we're gonna
have to do is deaden you up it's gonna
hurt anyway we're gonna have to get the
old drill
and we're gonna take all that kids
to sleep
they give me a sleepover they don't do
that but they will numb you now listen
it's going to be all right
then bring your headphones down because
they're going to want to check your gums
i have a great dentist i got a great
[ __ ] dentist right near you're all
the same no no hold on this guy you want
somebody who's been doing it a long long
time they're a dentist you know my guy's
been
nobody
i got a guy next to you dr schaubs who's
shocked are you making this up he's got
real shoves chavez travis oh and he's
got he's mexican yeah he's argentinian
hunter
a [ __ ]
listen to me i've had a lot of dentists
i i i grew up overseas you know my
stepmom was a dentist now that's i
didn't know that yeah so growing up his
kid went all the time okay well that's
terrible no wonder you've been
traumatized now i hate him my guy i
don't get pain see this [ __ ]
knows how to do it where he he numbs
your gum shoots you in i don't feel
anything what part of the valley is he
is he in the valley he's right on he's
right on
on [ __ ] ventura he's right okay
from you he's 10 minutes at the most
literally i'll do that i think he's five
minutes from where's the last time he
had a cleaning dude 15 years yeah i'll
set it up i'll set it up now my teeth
are now here's the thing
they got to drill because they're
hurting right then they got to put a
temporary cap on it they got to put a
temporary yeah they did they just put a
gold cap on no because they have to they
have to mold it they gotta mold it they
gotta mold because you gotta have to
make sure there's no now the problem
with gold is that when you bite down you
gotta shave that gold down
it's gotta be perfect
so you just wanna make sure you don't
have any because your teeth got to fit
so there's a whole process to it well
you want to i'm going to do it he's got
gold i'm going i don't know
the two i want to do it
i'm going through it right now i'm going
through right now it's exhausting yeah
you just went to oh you just went really
oh i'm going through it right now
because my my crown cracked so i have to
oh dude that's the [ __ ] now i'm going to
do i'm going to do invisalign but cool
thing is you don't take them all they
just do a laser you can do a visualize
again and then they they order it and
then i'm here and my guy dr schaubs is
the number one invisalign like uh
distributor in in some way is invisalign
that like the little plastic where it's
like the retainer yeah yeah you know
where it makes you talk weird yeah
yeah but who goes to the dentist
you go like normal cat you have nice i
don't remember the last time i was at
the dentist i think when i was a kid why
are they so white i know you think
they're like braces as a kid uh yeah i
had braces when i was really young
because i had a terrible overbite
but did you have to hold the milk carton
by a button and [ __ ] like my brother
no i didn't have a severe to the point i
had cousins who had to have the like uh
what was it called the head the retainer
thing yeah yeah the headgear
nerd alert yeah they had to wear they
had the rubber band yeah that's jay jay
had all that jay because his overbite
was so bad he had to uh take a gallon of
milk put a uh button on it and string
and hold it with his teeth for like
exercise wow do you know how lucky we
are we have dentistry like like most
people in the world up until very
recently including in britain and stuff
your teeth just sucked your teeth would
just fall out
i mean i watched this uh there's two
documentaries on uh did you watch the 14
peaks or the out of the alpinist this is
the climbing mountains yeah
oh well you walk okay
okay okay is it where they get all the
gear and climb up the mountains well the
[ __ ]
the nepalese guy who who basically was
like all these all these guys who climb
mount everest yeah like all these like
westerners who's carrying their [ __ ]
who's carrying the sherpas it's the
sherpas yeah and they're just not sherpa
they're my sherpa they never have a name
so this guy who was in the british he
went for the gurkha special forces which
is like you know they work with the with
the british you know special forces so
the sherpas that each base can't yeah
they're the ones that lead the whites up
the mountain yeah and he was the first
gurkha to be invited
into
the sas like the special air service
like delta sherpa the complete badass
he's sherpa yeah i'm a badass
you're a servant what are you a sharper
sure he's a sherpa i thought he leads
him up the mountain yeah yeah he's a
girl
brian he was he was a nepalese guy who
went into the group they know that
mountain back to their hands you can't
climb mountain without them so so they
did his vo max they did this thing at
the british special force thing when
they trained this and uh they've never
seen anything like it they've never seen
anyone because white blood cells are
through the roof because he lives on
this yeah so they've never seen any one
test like that they had this thing where
the the best guy lasted
he lasted three minutes he could have
kept going and they looked at like how
he can deal with oxygen they've never
seen anything like it in their life so
so so you know lives up there there are
14 there are 14 um peaks that you that
that and one guy reinhold metzger who's
this famous mountaineer
climbed now you you in k2 which is the
tallest peak in the world or in pakistan
actually yeah
uh you have a 25 chance of dying so one
in four people die climate why
avalanches um all kinds of crazy [ __ ]
can happen and mainly the weather kicks
up you get stuck up there all night
great time you're [ __ ] get stuck up
there all the way i have no desire to do
the worst idea are you kidding me why
why the worst thing in the world so
somebody climbed 14 and it took them 16
years like that's like a big deal so
this sherpa who then became an sas guy
because his wife was saying i knew he
was crazy he was the only gurkha to ever
become a special forces guy in the
british special sas and he goes i'm
going to climb all 14 peaks
in seven months by himself no he had a
team of sherpas sherpas he had all his
sherpa all his boys
so what strippers look like jenna
they're really small yeah they're small
and kind of thick small like he walks to
the mountains they're not they're not
big he walks a little bit no they're
like ewoks sure
get people around on star wars but but
like bring up the guy from 14 peaks it's
like he's you see him and he's seen that
guy smiling
your life is in his hands meanwhile
they're carrying like 100 guys they're
like that but that guy kills it yeah but
they can like they can carry a hundred
pounds on their back all the way up it's
nuts oh my god oh wait there was
scroll down chin
what do they got on their back right
there right there in the blue yeah so
they they that's what they carry they're
carrying your [ __ ] couch and they put
it on their head dude see how he's
carrying him someone was like hey dude
i'll climb it but i don't know you know
what's in there bro they can carry it
all the way that's why you find oxygen
tanks you need water
you need food you need every coffee and
do and oh and in the in 14 peaks they
came across dudes who were dying they
were stuck up in the mountains yeah when
you eat them back up there no they'd
have to go back up there but sometimes
it's pretty i don't want to give it too
much who's that
that's the [ __ ] right there
that that's the crazy dude and when he
went up k2 they go there are avalanches
three people have already died you can't
do it and he goes i'll go up at one in
the morning when that ice is concrete
and he goes up there meanwhile there's
footage of them he's trying to save a
guy and he won't leave him behind
because he he fought in iraq he fought
in afghanistan yes yeah
and and got got shot and all that but
he's a complete fighter i don't need to
watch it well i know you don't need to
watch it now he kind of covered it i
think you'd love it i think anybody
would normally
dude
he's trying to save this dude yeah and
they go like this and he's trying i'm
giving a lot of this away but he's
trying to save the guy and they go they
go you did you hear his
sherpa guy say in in nepalese he goes
you got to leave him brother or we're
all going to die you can't there's no
more oxygen left and you see him let him
go you see him let his head cause i've
never left anybody behind and he see him
let him go it was [ __ ] crazy wow but
the point to your point
seven months of like he climbed all 14
peaks in seven months which
ronald messer did it in 16 years it's
honestly friendly as [ __ ] he's so nice
well they went up and rescued dude so
they they were on their way and this
[ __ ] guy was stuck up there they
latched on to helicopters they'd never
done it they were terrified the
helicopter latches them on like this
picks them up
brings them out to their you know this
[ __ ] crazy place they see the dude
they wait with them all [ __ ] night
with oxygen
you know because you'll die without the
oxygen yeah and then they get them out
they get them out somehow and it was
[ __ ] i should have no desire to do it
none i have something i like that [ __ ]
but that's just not appealing i haven't
it's cool to see someone do it though
about someone doing it well the other
one is the alpinist right where i'm
watching this [ __ ] alpinist
alex hummold is like well the only
crazier guy than me the only guy who
does the craziest [ __ ] he was this 25
year old guy
and you see what he does you watch what
he does
and you just go so you have no ropes and
you're climbing oh you're climbing all
the hardest things that people say it's
impossible
and then and i'm not going to say how it
ends but he dies for sure i mean
he died yeah he died hey what happened
what happened to hype on squid game it's
not even in the popular like trending
it's been done thing on netflix now it's
just over made its rounds yeah it's just
so many people watching it was so hyped
amount of time it's just over everybody
watching you know like you're looking
for something to watch last night i'm
like what happened to squid game it's
just well i think now it's that 14 peaks
thing right i think that's like one of
the top things that the 14 people the
thing you just watched yeah i was
recommended on there for sure i i think
you'd like it i know what you mean
though it's like for me it's like i have
no idea i'm just not into it what i like
that i appreciate them with the hard
work and the dedication i appreciate
that well i like the way they talk about
like they have guys who talk about how
difficult how impossible it is and how
dangerous i assume that you know yeah
but it's cool it's cool to hear their
insight yeah but when they tell you that
you have a 50 chance of dying if you
climb the mountain now and they do it
anyway i'm always like
i mean
and you can see the people who are the
daredevils who are like but if i don't
do it i'll regret it the rest of my life
yeah meanwhile
you're not going to want to die that way
it's going to suck yes you don't have
[ __ ] about squirrel yeah i guess it just
got so
hyped that people are over it now
can i see your tattoo now oh yeah
oh yeah we can see it's still pretty
juicy
well it's a little dry
now it's a little dry now very green who
is that that's boston
okay and then tiger's up here i can't
pull it off what's that he's a zombie
because he says chombi oh dude i can see
his brain yeah yeah all right so that's
your son
yeah then tiger's here as a zombie i'm
not mad at that no that's cool yeah i'm
not every morning says chambi you can't
say zombie
so you got tiger up here in the boxes
right here that's that's disturbing but
in a good way yeah
all right yes here's crazy that guy dan
smith is so [ __ ] good you can't
really see it now because it's healing
he's a cute zombie yeah he's cute as
[ __ ] zombie
got his brain matter showing but he's a
zombie dude all right chambi yeah
it's pretty good
taking a while no easiest tattoo i've
ever got really but dan smith has such a
light touch wow yeah i didn't barely
felt it yeah he's great it's taking
longer
he's done my last like did did you
did you watch the fight
dan smith this thing did you post it
did you guys post it yet i don't think
we posted it
look at that
look at that boy right there there you
go
all right
creatures of habit is not just oatmeal
dude it's optimized oats you know what
that means
vitamin d3 you got omega-3s you got
probiotics you have digestive enzymes
okay dude it's the highest protein
content of any instant oatmeal in the
market and guess what it tastes
fantastic and it's incredibly good for
you put in the hot water or your coffee
in under three minutes you got it there
it goes dude i put it in my hot coffee i
put i'm sorry i don't put hot coffee
that's weird i put it with hot water and
three minutes ready to go my girl likes
the overnight in the fridge with almond
milk you put in a smoothie you microwave
it all right it's fantastic all right
and uh you gotta get a good breakfast
you want some fast delicious healthy
keep it in your bag dude we got you baby
let's go to
creaturesofhabit.com use the promo code
fighter at checkout for 20 off your
first order that's
k-r-e-a-t-u-r-e-s-o-f-h-a-b-i-t
com use promo code fighter at checkout
for 20 off your first order creatures of
habit.com promo code fighter for
tormentsoft your favorite oatmeal there
you go um did i wha oh the you talk
about the jake paul woodley i did watch
it my son was sleeping next to me
and so i uh couldn't
have volume on but i
bought it on my phone
and watch it on my phone yeah
so stupid no i hate this but
it looked like um there was a lot of
that
sort of what you talk about with with
where inexperienced fighters just keep
clapping i don't think it's an
experience i think it jesus christ i
think it was uh
it was crazy because um
they fought each other before and they
knew the strength of each one it's tough
in rematches man it's like when i fought
andre alaska we're training partners so
you get a boring fight you know what the
other one wants to do really well you
know what he you think he knows what
you're gonna do so you're tentative that
was my takeaway from it i was like in
the first five rounds like holy [ __ ]
fellas i thought woody was gonna go for
broke because his back was against well
he's lost five fights in a row yeah so
it's like come on dude he really didn't
and then yeah thank god it ended like
this because it would have hurt jake
paul stock so bad if if it would have
went to decision like that for eight
rounds like it was rough boy that that
[ __ ] that knockout
oh but now it's off to the races for
jake paul now you're getting big big boy
names yeah you're getting you know like
nate diaz's the conor mcgregor's jorge
mosby dolls anderson silvas
everyone's coming after him now all
right now you're getting the big boys
yeah because you got their attention you
do that to a hall of famer and woodley
you're getting their attention yeah so
now it's off to the races for jacob
everybody wants a piece of that now now
people are going to play he's calling
out everybody now he's now people
willing to play ball
who is who would you put him up right
now for what's what fight would you like
to see yeah um i would love an eight i
think the nate diaz built up be
fantastic it would right because i think
whoever he picks he's going to be an
underdog next he's got it he's tough got
his hands full i think the worst case
scenario firmness we and i think he's
the highest on their odds to fight next
the worst case would be himself in silva
i don't think he's being understood no
anderson just beat julio chevas junior
who's a multi-world champion that'd be a
nightmare for him anderson's very slow
should be a night
but they you know i i guess logan was
potentially was fight
uh anderson paul or anderson silva i
knew that for you know
um that was supposed to go down so
they say anna silva's the most likely
the next guy i don't like that for him i
don't think it's as big of a draw as
like a diaz or mcgregor but the thing is
with mcgregor and diaz the dana white's
gonna have to play ballroom and he hates
jake paul but i do think
dana realizes that that is they're gonna
do it regardless so you might as well
cash in on it yes so i think he allows
one of those two to do it can they can
they can someone like nadia's retire
from the ufc and nope he cannot nope you
have to fight out your contract wow
because if you if you just retire your
contract gets frozen how many fights if
i left one more like oh i think because
he didn't fight it goes it prolongs it
six months
it's tough dude if you don't fight just
prolongs the contract so he wants to
fight in january so he could fight in
january and then you know fight jake uh
you know quarter two of 2022. like if
like i'm retired right
it didn't terminate my contract if i
came back tomorrow i was like okay i'm
back the ufc owns my wow contract wow i
still have i think three fights on there
damn so you're never getting out of it
until you fight out of it
you want to fight how many of you yeah
how many fighters are you and me
what like
sorry what
usually they do six flight deals six
right oh okay they lost one for six
flights so you can't jump around it
elsewhere yeah
um it's since about francis francis has
one fight left on his contract they
wanted to renegotiate he was like no you
you paid me more money so he's risking
it now he's fighting cyril gone and he's
hoping once he becomes champ he'll have
more leverage to either negotiate ufc
and get paid big bucks yeah or he wants
to jump ship and fight like tyson fury
that's his plan
that'd be a that's
he's i don't advise it but i got into
his agent about like i don't like that
for him man he's like but i know the pay
is good i just don't like that for him
no v how was uh
mcgregor were able to do that mayweather
fight because dana and the ufc were
co-promoters the ufc has to be in on it
and i think dana he's such a smart dude
he's
it's gonna happen i guarantee you jake
fights nate diaz and conor mcgregor now
dana can play hard bongo nope we don't
want to be part of it and connor and
nate only have one or two fights left on
the contract okay so you can have them
fight and do their thing and then when
they get out that fight's happening dude
if i'm dana mike it's gonna happen in my
watch yeah i might as well get a piece
of this [ __ ] connor connor's uh
interesting because he's he's much
smaller guy than 190 right now he's 190
now yeah
what does that do to his speed and his
nose yeah and his endurance yeah i know
he's always had an issue with endurance
that's a problem and and uh but i do
think jake can crack i do think jake's
next fight whoever it is he used to be
an underdog for the first time well when
i what i see about jake that's like
really when he gets in there he just
throws that and he's just explosive
speed yeah and somebody
these people with disrespect was like at
some point you gotta give the kids some
respect he's four no he's knocked out
every opponent in his face look at any i
challenge you any boxer floyd tyson fury
mike tyson look at their first four
fights
jake has fought tougher opponents
correct than anybody else in the world
at 4-0 correct and knocked him out dude
at a high level
in front of millions of people
he trains really hard he gets in the
ring in front of all those people and
puts it all on the line
say whatever you want yeah you do that
that's [ __ ] hard to do and scary yeah
at some point you've got to give him
some credit with him i do and he started
three years ago mm-hmm yeah dude he was
terrible he was three years ago he was
terrible yeah you said wilder started
late in the game too right
uh uh tommy fury did wilder started when
he's like 21-22 oh heavyweight's
different though headway you can get a
lot
away he's taking it very soon okay and i
think his brother is too right isn't
logan training looking a little
different jake's doing you know really
well jake's one of them wants a career
logan's looking for the mike tyson's the
connors that's it he's not fighting
anybody else is a huge payday yeah he's
not trying to the best match up he's
just toughest guy biggest name most
money yeah jake's looking for an actual
career
is jorge mosbid a nightmare for uh jake
tough fight yeah tough fight but
moswell's not happening unless the ufc
plays balls but yeah because you know
he's tied up in that contract but nate
yes would be a lot of fun
nate's had a lot of experience against
guys who can crack it's a great fight
yeah and just to build up them talking
everybody
oh yeah at some point you got to give
jake his doom man you got to give him i
mean you can hate on you maybe his
antics on youtube i get it i get it at
some point flatlining woodley like that
a ufc hall bonafide first ballot hall of
famer i don't give a [ __ ] who you are in
your fourth fight how insane that is
that's nuts
we're not talking about like a tko i'm
talking flat line he's never been
flatlined like ever sir
also in the latter part of the [ __ ]
the sixth round i think it was and then
throwing that just just having the balls
to throw that thing open your restaurant
the the thing that showtime needs to do
i'm sure they're going to edit on below
the belt because i said this but the
thing showtime needs to do is put on a
better card that was a [ __ ] dude give me
my [ __ ] money back oh the card i
didn't see that i didn't see anything it
was frank gore versus darren williams
they were awful they were talking about
that that was crazy you had two guys who
were like 20-0 but they fought cupcakes
and split decisions [ __ ] fight i thought
the the girls uh
the girl's a monster but she's the
biggest favorite on the card so you know
she's going to win so you're kind of
turning out of that they just got to put
on a better overall card for the money
uh does jake
give tyson uh tommy fury fits
he's
he's passed that tommy fear is the
easiest fight you'd ever have is that
right yeah i mean yeah that's a waste of
time
this was a much tougher fight than tommy
fury
meatball was heated i just didn't see
tyron i just looked like he just wasn't
i just think he's been over fighting for
a long time in a way good for him i
don't know it's that i just again i
think some when you rematch guys it's
[ __ ] tough dude
you know what he's looking for horrible
like beating they're horrible it wasn't
a beating the knockout was bad there's
no beating no that's what i mean
mainly because he called me with a
shading grin on his face right after the
uh because you were going for jake paul
i just i just know it i didn't i don't
really care either way it's entertaining
to me you don't like jake paul no no no
i wasn't i wasn't mad like i was more in
like disbelief in shock at what i
witnessed like are you one of those guys
that thinks it's a conspiracy no no i i
think that was a fair he won that fair
starbucks goes bro come on whoever said
that i got it starbucks shows come on
bro lowers your hand how long you been
fighting excuse me
dude make my [ __ ] drink so i can get
out of here so i don't have to do this
wow if you throw it and let it
throw it from his hip and you think he
wants to be a meme face down ass up yeah
that's what you think you would agree to
would like people why do people think is
that because they don't want to know
because they don't want to give jake the
the that's right
they don't want to give him credit
they're trying everything they can to
not give them credit yeah same thing
with logan floyd they're doing what
always whatever they can to not give him
whatever because people like that are
threatening they're threatening because
they they what they're doing he's
[ __ ] up the ecosystem they're doing
the impossible too they're going for
something and people that can't dream
like that go oh well he's cheating or
yeah well they did that to you with
stand up oh yeah i mean anytime you step
out you just keep going and eventually
they're like all right you just prove
everything eventually they'll get
exhausted
well those haters have no work ethic
yeah so eventually it if they had a work
ethic they wouldn't be hating when you
still eventually they're just
like trying something that nobody's done
before and you're really going for
something what happens is the people
that don't have the you you remind
people
that they should be doing that and they
don't like that so what they do is they
try to like bring you down yeah well
also it's like where are you getting
your information that you believe it's
it was rigged or fixed like well they're
where where are you getting but they're
not they're you know they have no
backbone there's no info yeah yeah
where's the info like where it helps him
deal with his no one no one that's ever
done anything from steve jobs to albert
einstein whoever none of those people
have ever
not received tremendous criticism
criticism
they began naturally
insulting yeah
and i get that it's just like okay if
you're gonna say that
where's your information you don't you
don't have to you know you don't have to
these days yeah elon musk everybody said
i i know so many people who were like
this is never going to work tesla's a
[ __ ] company it's going to go down he
got a bunch of government subsidies and
there's one thing after another yeah the
electric car is never going to work and
he was like shut up shut up shut up yeah
yeah yeah keep saying someone has to do
it somebody who's the guy because
obviously he knows something that you
know oh he's brilliant dude and his
number one thing is he believes yeah
like me like me and lex friedman were
talking about that we're taught he goes
do you think
rogan's club can be like the comedy
store of austin and go
you know if anyone can do it it's tim
it's just tough because you don't have
the same
you know group of guys that are in town
ever you know all the time monday
through [ __ ] thursday like you don't
have that but it's in the world but if
anybody's going to get it done it's
rogan and friedman said the same thing
he goes yeah it's because the here's the
similarities between rogan and uh elon
tesla the the similarities between uh
elon and rogers they believe he wasn't
so powerful dude he goes in my business
you find someone who believes they do
crazy [ __ ] oh you be a you'd be a fool
to hate on him for doing this club rogan
yeah he'll take over yeah i know it's
game set match what do you see though
crazy
what do you got jen
how's that neck gin where's your neck by
the way did you really quickly before
you did you see that
that it was on sportscenter that black
dude who just i think he must have been
a football player who is in a suit and a
tie and just walks up to 675 cold and
just goes oh yeah yeah he just lifted it
i was like you got to see that it's on
espn yeah yeah on their instagram handle
or where yeah
i think mark marcus go to sportscenter
on instagram i think it is and i was
live on instagram i'm sorry curl 675 no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no no no no no no no no no no
he just doubted it like it was uh
it's rolled up in this yeah i keep going
this guy right there no no no yeah it
says after he realizes
675. it has to be him
i don't know
no this is a no it wasn't even like that
not nothing like that
where the [ __ ] is it it's a smart story
mark did post it it's gotta be i'm gonna
marks there it is there it is there it
is right there right there watch this
watch this
you guys jack someone says sir you
forgot to struggle
jesus christ
i'm sorry sir i'm sorry
are you wearing rings though is that
rings
the jacket adjustment how did you just
walk up there let me not no wide stance
either look at that look look at how
close
[Music]
yeah he's jack but you just still you're
like i'm how much how much is that 675.
675
i mean the bar bends he's just like me
let me just pick this [ __ ] up that's
nuts yeah
he probably saw guys in football
not really
that's weird
all right what do you got jen
all right here we go
so recently it was uh
this information was released where lee
harvey oswald was in contact with a
member of the kgb for two months before
the shooting uh and cia was told a year
prior that russia was trying to pay a
hit man any hit man a hundred thousand
dollars to kill the president
so these are these are from official
government files from the white house
that biden has to release he held some
back again but he's forced to release
them december 2022.
and apparently those have the juicy
details well the rv oswald had been in
cuba cuba and so he and he was
definitely a communist yeah but they
they have him they have the phone
conversations on paper of them agreeing
to a
fee to take out jfk
which is interesting
wait did you say they have to release
this on in 2022 the rest of it is was
that like a thing that was said like
back in the day yeah in the year 2020
and trump wanted to release all of them
when he first got into office he
promised when he solved them he went
through and went i can't really solve
them it's gonna it's gonna [ __ ] the
public up the thing is so i'm so curious
what what else is in there and uh but
then then you got the jack ruby and the
mafia connection you have what was it
sam giancana yeah who was involved so
like
the new orleans mafia
there's so much that goes into it and
then have you seen uh
what's his name
oh what's his [ __ ] name the jfk movie
stone stone oliver stone he has a
documentary on hbo right now
fantastic really do they have the doctor
that got his hands for did the autopsy
first on jfk and goes so he's on record
saying without a doubt a bullet came
through the front shot him in the neck
without a doubt yeah without a doubt a
day later after fbi just talked to me
was ah listen i went too fast it's not
that's just they did a trachea i didn't
see that it didn't come through the
front but he held his throat oh yeah
you see him do this
and then the magic boat that they found
they said it came from when they were
doing cpr and jfk they said the bullet
that shot them in the back while they're
doing cpr fell out i found the no not a
chance no they had a forensic guy going
like that but the bullet was in perfect
condition yeah it doesn't work like that
yeah
and then also through the doctor's
autopsy the first one get his hands on
him to get his hands on him
he was saying the shot came and blew up
the back like the all points signs that
was all from the front one from the back
two from the front
but then they said it's the only time
when autopsy history ever where the fbi
agents were in there with the doctor
doing the laptops they tell them what to
do first time ever usually they're not
allowed in there
and then and then his original files in
the autopsy
they were burned why were they burned he
goes it had the president's blood all
over him i didn't want to be like a
keepsake for some insane person out
there so we had to get rid of them
so strange dude damn so weird
the whole thing is very interesting oh
it's so fast although you can get hit i
i was there's a guy who i know who has
done enough of that
the
special force guy said you can get hit
like when you get hit this way
your your your explodes it'll explode
out yeah so it doesn't necessarily mean
you get hit this way because you can get
hit in the back of the head and it'll
slow backwards because it creates a
vacuum so it goes in and goes and the
vacuum goes about that's all fine
explain the bullet to the front
oh i mean please explain that and then
the matchbook they were shown the path
that they originally said happened like
through the neck one through the back
and they're saying the magic boat and
they're showing the trap the trajectory
of it that went through him through you
know the other guy into his leg like
it's just insane like it's just common
science that this would never happen so
for the public to believe that this
magic bullet did all this he's like it's
just insane right and these are like
experts on it like it just doesn't make
any sense
so everyone's just waiting for december
so what do they think
there was a there was a rifle team they
yeah they think it was a team yeah they
think it was a team and
from what they're
kind of saying that those documents come
out in 2022 of december and ca had
something to do but rifles are so loud
wouldn't they wouldn't people have heard
they did and they noticed that that's
right on the grassy knoll they ran this
way towards jfk not back
bring that up chin
really yeah they because and then they
heard shots behind them so they duck and
then run forward
and then they said they saw two men
running into the train tracks wow
it's so interesting i mean the grass you
know people ran away
oh that was a spot to like the
to the right to the right yeah yeah
where they had that we could sign up for
all that [ __ ]
it's really interesting
i wonder if there's a video on youtube
of it
see by a majority of witnesses the area
from where shots were fired
wow eyewitnesses and then also what else
is interesting is the umbrella man
the umbrella man he said he had the
umbrella up because it was a protest
against something jfk's dad did it makes
no sense but it's very
strange that he would open and close the
umbrella and they think he was signaling
to them that it was like giving them
so interesting that guy passed away now
but
that's so funny it's so interesting the
most interesting is that doc do the
autopsy changing all his [ __ ] it's so
strange like why would you do all that
dude yeah yeah they said the fbi agents
were in there and they changed the chaos
of that where everybody's in there i get
the chaos and a lot of [ __ ] can get lost
in translation and chaos but they the
the the doctor who passed away now his
best friend they worked together on all
these surgeries he said over the years i
always brought it up he always shot it
down and we shot it down they said then
one one day we got done doing like a
seven hour procedure and we're in the
surgeons uh like hanging out area
getting coffee he was come on man what'd
you see what like i know you didn't say
it on the thing what'd you see and he
looked and goes without a doubt someone
shot him through the front
he was without a doubt
and that guy was his best friend he goes
you know he just felt forced to live
that lie in which he hated for the rest
of his life which was somebody said tell
people that the bullet came yeah the
government told him like this is how it
went down and he's like no it didn't
and then he's on record saying it when
the fbi weren't forced to back then
came to you and said hey well that's
what that's what he said he said he told
his best friend he goes they came to me
and this is this is the narrative
he passed away now but his best friend's
still alive so but then that raises the
question but see because now was it the
mafia was it the cia was it the soviets
i think all of them i think it was
combination they all had one agenda
and you think lyndon b johnson also had
they [ __ ] hated each other
and london b johnson's ties to
everything's insane yeah he was a
nefarious guy yeah bad dude terrible so
so then so then the theory would go that
lyndon johnson
worked with the cia groups in the cia
who were embarrassed by the bay of pigs
operations to hire
mercenaries how do we do this let's get
sam giancana who got him sam giancana
who got him elected and then his brother
bobby ended up going after the mafia
double time so he had an axe to grind so
they knew that they had people they
actually extort him out of texas out of
the united states came back in through
new orleans yeah that well they they so
maybe the c.i.a
but harvey oswald was also we know he
was in cuba
and he met russia and spent time in
russia and they have them on the phone
agreeing to the compensation to take him
out right so now i'm confused but but
then what's confused i think he was part
and he's escaped because you can't be
like oh mafia took him out and then not
have anybody to take the fall so you
have harvey the way i would do it is i
would have also his gun was like a
rent-a-gun it's not even like a property
you could have harvey oswald do it and
then you could have
another assassination team do it too
it's too complicated because then who
hired that assassin team right so that
this would so did harvey lee harvey
oswald pull the trigger then or they
think he was a stupid he was the he was
the fall guy
but what was he there and then what he
worked there he worked there he was
never working there's no there's no
evidence that he was ever up in that
tower fingerprints on the
gun sure
sure
that we know of they don't know but
what's interesting he was in the
comments area at the time and there's
multiple witnesses go we went down and
up the stairs and he was never there he
was in the commissary at the time during
the assassination he didn't know what
was going on
why did he run away though
yeah who knows you know it's all
interesting it's so fascinating
i can't wait for those other papers get
ready because sometimes all these
december
starts folding in on each other and i'm
trying to figure out what then is the
theory
what's the most plausible theory
mafia mafia mao there him and his
brother were cracking down super hard in
the mafia
landon b johnson and the rest of them
were all intertwined they used to all
hang out at the same speakeasy
johnson in the mafia
okay johnson jfk [ __ ] hated each
other they wouldn't talk they hated each
other
disdain for each other wow
mm-hmm interesting man i think it's a
combination of everything oswald's the
fall guy but he was also down for the
cause the mafia orchestrated it funded
it cia was like yeah
here's what's happening
get him out of here huh
it's so interesting yeah well my
favorite conspiracy
i doubt it
then there's always a chance
there's always a chance is there a
chance it was lee harvey oswald
and it was just him
like what are the chances of that versus
all this stuff
why would jack ruby shoot him that's
really weird why would jack ruin that
ruby and then also [ __ ] mafia guy and
then also jack ruby and
and the harvey oswald they jack ruby
goes if you want the full story
interview me and they're like we're fine
he's like no no i'm in prison i'm down
to tell you what really happened and
they never never no one
well that's a weird thing too so
here's my here's what's really weird to
me about the jack ruby thing the
narrative was that he was so upset for
jackie that he wanted to avenge her no
come on which is really [ __ ] right
unless he was a patriot he was dying of
cancer and he was like [ __ ] i'm going
out with a bang and he was that angry
but then his title they try to use his
ties to the mafia he owned the number
one nightclub all the mafia guys went to
and he was part he was like a low-level
mafia guy and then the cop the cops just
allowed him to hang around the station
and the cops were also hung out that
mafia club doing there yeah the whole
thing is [ __ ] really weird it's so
strange it's so fascinating and then
then he was put in jail and he died of
cancer without able to speak to anybody
what kind of cancer kills you that
quickly though how long was he in jail i
don't know how long was jack ruby in
jail for yeah find that out
let me see what cancer also remember
harvey oswald let's say you were super
anti-jfk
just a month after his tumor a month
after
so he's spread to his brain and liver
so let's say you are super anti-america
anti-jfk if you're lee harvey oswald
you're telling me you wouldn't take
credit for it
at any point you wouldn't be like yeah
what do you mean oh he never admitted to
the murder yeah any time when they
arrested him he was on record like i i
didn't do this yeah so it's like why why
did he admit it is what you're saying
yeah like i know we know he killed you
know we know he definitely killed him
but so wait how did how did jack ruby
what was the cancer it said he died in
67.
um acted alone the warren commission
have you read the warrant commission
report oh yeah yeah yeah the what the
warrant commission report that's the
commission they put together to figure
out if there was more than one shooter
the kenny assessor and it's dude the way
they did that it's such a crack of [ __ ]
what
just the how uh
johnson and everyone orchestrate all
that like it's such a crock of [ __ ]
um
so like four years sort of he was in
there for four years
roughly
and was never allowed to talk
clayty was he was distraught over the
president's assassination
i mean it is possible he was such a
loved guy
and he knew he was dying and he was like
[ __ ] this man right
right no no good yeah i do i think it's
a gun
jacob rubenstein
says i may believe he killed oswald to
keep him from revealing a larger
conspiracy in in his trial ruby denied
the charge maintaining that he was
acting of patriotism in march 1964 he's
found guilty and since the death took
three four years
but while he was on this first trial he
said i was acting out of patriotism i
can see that
i can see that i really can't he's dying
and he's like you [ __ ] killed my
president [ __ ] this you know i'm going
out with a bang
i can see that there are people who
really feel very strongly about that
stuff
so
in 1978 the house select committee on
assassination included in preliminary
reports that kay was probably
assassinated as a result of a conspiracy
that may have involved multiple shooters
and organized crime
committees fines as with the findings of
the warren commission continue to be
disputed and that's when he transitioned
into a female gymnast does that appear
that's him there wow that's jack ruby
took first place even with cancer that's
impressive all right what else you got
jen it's [ __ ] fascinating though yeah
yeah it is cool
so louis ck just uh
released his newest stand-up special on
his website and people were upset
because while they were watching uh the
recent episode of snl the very first ad
break was an advertisement that louis
bought
for his special so yeah but you know nbc
has to green light that yeah so who are
you so a lot of people were initially
mad at snl and then people pointed that
out that nbc is the one we also know
he's a writer inside live for years yeah
yeah
saturday live alumni he was a lead
writer for many years
yeah yeah i watched it i watched this
and who was mad really i wanted to watch
it
i liked it it's refreshing you kind of
just i mean he [ __ ] goes up there and
just he's hilarious just so funny i saw
some slangs jokes yeah
okay
it was funny it was funny special
and then trevor noah is currently
undergoing a lawsuit with a surgeon
where he is claiming that his surgeon
that specializes in elbows and i believe
uh hips
somehow left him sick sore lame and
disabled after his surgery in the later
part of 2020.
it is not currently disclosed what he
had done a lot of people were
speculating that maybe it was a cosmetic
procedure but his surgeon actually only
does uh does not do any cosmetic
procedures so we're thinking he has an
issue with his arm right now or his knee
and now he's like permanently that's the
surgeon right there
i wonder how [ __ ] up he is yeah [ __ ]
up enough to have a lawsuit
yeah that can't be good
damn
all righty
oh so a fan was at a dolphins game with
his girlfriend where he planned to
propose to her and when the proposal
goes up on the jumbotron they then pan
over to the girlfriend where she's
sitting alone because the guy is gone
it's speculated that maybe he was at a
concession stand in the restroom i guess
he didn't know the exact moment they
were going to play this video
but wow
the proposal video went up it was just
her sitting alone oh like hand over her
mouth shocked that her boyfriend was
nowhere
[ __ ] [ __ ] hilarious
poor guy he's just getting a [ __ ] hot
dog it's a nightmare
let's just get for asking a girl to ask
to marry at a dolphin
you're already asking for trouble with
that [ __ ] yeah i mean the dolphins win
i always find that yeah they won seven
or else because there are a lot of
examples where the girl's like i i can't
she runs out
i saw some dude on world star and i
think it was japan or korea asked his
girl to marry him he had like this whole
car and gifts and [ __ ] she said no man
he freaked out oh started smashing the
car and [ __ ] i'm sure that's a little
embarrassing first of all why you got to
go that hard for a proposal
maybe that's the culture over there
i don't know just go ahead and do it
yeah it's just like hey
you don't need all the videos and
publicly yeah
jumbotron and [ __ ]
that's it
what else you got jen
so there was a video of hitman holla who
is a cast member on wild and out that
went viral over the weekend because it
was a video of
uh him and his girlfriend cinnamon on
their anniversary where she was jacking
him off they were having sex and he was
putting it online under his close
friends story which
is basically a list compiled by the user
where it's people that they want to see
this but like specific set of stories
why would you send your friends you're
getting jacked up yeah i don't know
that's why i'm so confused he then had
to later come out and say you know what
it's all fun and games that's fine but
let's clear a few things up one my
girlfriend did know about it she's on my
close friend's list she actually green
lit it she also knows everyone on my
close friend's list so she's okay with
everybody seeing
that let's see this video
they took it down so fast but i found a
few screenshots yeah she's
had a real one yeah it's very but also
it was blurry like if you sent me chris
a snap of your jackie off but hey dude
don't send these you know yeah i mean so
this is one of it this was a video and
the user had
out the dick but it's
his girlfriend jacking him off and then
there is another
video that he does i guess there are a
bunch of stories that were posted he put
a very tiny video of like him [ __ ]
his girlfriend from uh higher point of
view i mean obviously he's proud of what
he's working with and he's obviously my
thing is i don't know anyone personally
who would do this and put that like
so you're like this sounds like no this
sounds like a swinger's ring that's what
this sounds like this sounds like maybe
he's got a his close friends are a group
of like-minded individuals
and they all get off on they they swing
and [ __ ] what they're going to be doing
to each other the next time around
that's what it feels like to me
all right i don't know i think there's
no video here
no they took the video down by the time
i was trying to find it but if you look
at his story you can see there are quite
a few
little dots
all right well we're here he's obviously
and now twitter was in a frenzy and he's
he was like the hottest topic all the
girls were thirsting out good for him i
never heard of him and now we're talking
about him yeah mm-hmm i love wildling
now he's yeah he's originally a battle
rapper that's cool yeah it's just weird
to film your girl doing that yeah then
send your back and i think he's
yes
he said there were at least 30 women on
his close friends list he doesn't then
say how many men were in there but he
says my girlfriend is cool with all 30
of the girls on my clothes
yeah they're like damn so yeah
right brian is probably some yeah maybe
it is [ __ ] oh yeah she's she brings
girls home she's in the girls she likes
watching him
man that's a whole situation
let it roll [ __ ] it dick on him that's
all he's got a dick on him i mean god
bless
is that well that's that's this girl
with the red hair uh this one is not his
girl this is an instagram comedian this
one
that's is that his girl cinnamon
yes i think yes that's cinnamon i
approve good luck she was shot in a
break-in wow
wow she's super hot
oh my god
oh or is that the one i'm not as into
this one
well
either way good
he sits this girl though you know
people gonna bump
do you think you know what
they're gonna bump bump i guess i didn't
get this out yeah
i'm saying next one for god's sake
it's not covered at all you know
get us out of here means close the show
too though
um
let's see here
oh so this looked pretty crazy
this kid in mexico is only like 16 years
old
the cartel wanted him to transport drugs
for him he didn't want to do it so they
chopped off his fingers i was a trigger
finger huh [ __ ]
just awesome 16 year old yep
jesus christ dude [ __ ]
just the worst people on the planet
pageant found the boy and his parents
five siblings staying in the shelter
they're extremely poor people who are
just beginning to understand they have
rights jesus christ yeah they do this
[ __ ] to you that's [ __ ] awesome i
said and add that the boys teenage and
pre-teenaged sisters are also at risk of
being forced into sexual trafficking do
the families
oh [ __ ]
dude cut off finger's been a practice as
a method of torture intimidation by
mixing drugs
even celebrities have been targeted the
son
famous vincent fernandez who died this
month also lost his pointing fingers oh
oh i got to see that one chin where the
those tourists run in with this one
so this video popped up oh that's all
this is the one yeah these are americans
they're both you can tell they're
absolutely freaked out and they're in
mexico yeah
i think they're lovers
oh my god
i think they're both we just want a
couple yeah that's what i say
dude it ain't worth it to drive down to
mexico for them
wait watch watch homie
on the left oh watch if you pass out
he says
oh my god let's see who's he calling
right now no he's trying to show them
where they're going they're trying to
help him find their place
the cartels yeah someone said the cartel
was scared to get canceled
i guess
no
problem
he's patting his shoulders
the problem with the drug cartels is
that they're all linked up with the
government
and the police
so
okay we're gonna see me madre
you will wait
uh kenko
what's your name
what's your name i wouldn't ask that
like all right thank you
please don't kill us
[Music]
guns
so that's why he stopped what do you
speed up this isn't [ __ ] fast and
fierce nighttime definitely don't speed
up no let's not speed up no don't speed
up [ __ ] but you have a better chance
of getting getting god yeah you're not
doing any of that the survival rate
right there a little bit with christian
though like you're gonna bank on them
give me forgiveness yeah well you're not
okay so
so someone do evasive driving they have
[ __ ] automatic weapons yeah those
dudes it's going to light that down you
do that they're going to yeah they're
just going to fire especially when
they're that close oh the the worst
thing you can do you're in mexico
and what happens is when you drive
around the streets like that that kind
of [ __ ] happens oh you look and you got
shaken down before which is why i don't
do hard it'd be to hit a person in a
moving car you're at you
so am i driving and you tell me to gun
it
like that i don't know the streets don't
worry they just go like this
or they just pull up next to you
it's better if you think you're they're
going to kill you to stop yes yes
wouldn't you have a better chance of you
know you stop because they're going to
rob you or they're going to figure
something out but what are you going to
do
you're you're you don't know how many
people are there you don't you don't
know if they got homies down the road
worse for you to stop then no you don't
know how many people the only problem
the only problem is chris if you assume
there's gonna fire often like it's
guaranteed you're gonna be in a gunfight
you're dead at least this you can stop
you're not
a bullet you're not you're not out
driving an ak-47 you're going to piss
them off you got to drive like those are
the guys they're obviously looking for
somebody you take off like that they're
like oh those are the guys i don't know
what the answer is
the answer is you do what those [ __ ]
guys did you know i don't know if you
want to be that you know but just you're
not
the answer is very simple don't go to
mexico yes yes you don't drive around
like that in the streets like dude
that's the problem it's just too
dangerous now that's the errors he's
like we're going to see my mother in
cancun all right shut up
he's like it's okay it's [ __ ] good
it's crazy there there are no
consequences no nightmare
and cutting people now tulum is an issue
for them like it's not good uh papanau
yeah yeah yeah everybody was going there
on the chest i guess they came in on jet
skis and cancun started shooting in
cancun yeah like but tulum's the new one
because you should be like super safe
but they don't have the infrastructure
or the cops but and now we get such a
hot spot for celebrities and stuff
so now they're then yeah so now they're
in there a lot of people do drugs well
drugs attract the cartel like it's a
nightmare wait i thought i thought they
weren't going after tourists as much no
they are like nope now they are well so
so a lot of times the cartels own the
own the resorts okay okay or they have
they have something in it but the
problem is so what is that
the worst is when they're fighting each
other that's when people yeah so what
the result is like if the
this hotel doesn't make their payments
yeah they just say oh russians russians
and local politicians
what
two foreign tourists including us-based
travel influencer anal
yeah i don't want to be a sitting duck
yeah you know there's no cartel hawaii
and and the thing is like you're driving
around your car with your girl or
whatever your kids and that and a group
of ten men and two cars come up or they
there's a roadblock and they should do
that to you yeah yeah my thing is who
you're gonna call the federalists
they're in on it correct
that's right they're not so now you're
[ __ ] that noise that now you're at
the behest of armed gangs which is what
happens and oh you don't want to do our
bidding good how about we're going to
sell your daughter into sexual slavery
and cut your hands off which is what
they do [ __ ] you what else you got jen
this right here this holidays everybody
this punter apparently looks just like
bill burr i mean for the texas i know
that is [ __ ] crazy
holy [ __ ] he looks identical
someone said since when did bill burr
start punting for the text
i thought it was photoshopped so i'm
saying is that photoshop like no that's
him that's hilarious oh my god that's
really funny
that's great
i feel like punters are so much bigger
today than they used to be is that true
i don't know it just depends they used
to be always really skinny they're like
ex-soccer players you'd see them out
there you're like oh my god now they're
like somehow big guys
uh this one's just pretty crazy i saw
this this morning so remember tony say
from zappos who died mysteriously but
they found later on he was kind of like
he had mental issues and then he had
candles and then yeah he died
yeah [ __ ] so he has 500 kill himself oh
no they think he just made him made a
mistake and probably kicked over a
candle oh yeah and just got disoriented
but he's like balls deep in candles yeah
he got really into candles he was like
in a wooden shed and you know really
so he burned to death oh yeah oh
probably died of smoke ventilation but
yeah yeah he wasn't all there immensely
either that's why people were concerned
about him even jewel she sent out joe
rogan to i think that she was friends
with him and she realized he had he was
going through some issues yeah and that
someone needed to help him jewel the
singer the singer hell yeah i like her
and he's also friends with he was also
friends with joseph gordon-levitt and
some other celebrities too
but so this he had 500 million dollars
and
he had no will
but he had a bunch of sticky notes like
i guess thousands of them we had like
plans on them so they're his friends and
everyone that's supposed to get money
from him are trying to use that in court
to get split up as much of a sticky note
wrote this
he wrote it man he was high
30 million based on what's been three
months before he died no per journal
said
he would pay evansvold 450 to move to
park city and take out project manager
give him 20 share in the restaurant yeah
but you never went dude yeah but um
well you might have always inherited
that definitely should go to his family
yeah
that sucks
yeah
and let's end this on a high note oh do
you guys heard about this penguin stuff
yeah whatever
now she's saying she's saying she wasn't
yeah
but then of course the tennis something
tennis association doesn't really
believe it no and they're not gonna play
in china either do i
mean and this is a nice one
yeah
i think we saw that have you seen this
i've never seen this okay let me play
for it eats her hat well you think he
does
he's just [ __ ] with her he's [ __ ]
with her um did they take it all they're
just thinking oh yeah i think you can't
here we go
[Laughter]
[Music]
he's all psyched
sorry
my sister just gave me that time
god they're [ __ ] massive i know
so beautiful he's all just playing with
you [ __ ] it's wet
[Laughter]
that's free oh that's the nicest one oh
hyenas have great noses
oh wow
are jaguars the only big cats that can
swim
i know tigers swim well yeah tigers swim
like a [ __ ] yeah god that's a
nice video
just another happy note got some nose oh
you want to poke my nose i'll poke your
[ __ ] big nose
cutie it's not as soft as i thought no
my nose and you know as you get older
your nose gets a little more bulby it
gets a little bit well i think it's uh
doesn't stop growing your ears and nose
apparently you're ball set
i know right
heavier by the day
it feels like it's gotten bigger you
think it looks the same to me it's still
heavy crazy oh what do we got for you
kids wrap it up here uh where are we at
hollywood improv this wednesday sold out
but don't worry if you didn't get
tickets we have a bunch of hollywood
improv shows coming up in january and
february so shop and friends this
wednesday sold out but don't sweat it
because we'll have a bunch more shows
coming up next year
and then dania florida fort lauderdale
florida december 30 through january 1st
bringing the new year with your thick
friends chappelle lacey david lucas
myself
show thursday friday saturday then rally
north carolina is january 6 or january
8th that bad boy's almost sold out so
get tickets while you can
charlotte we gotta reschedule so we're
rescheduling charlotte because we have
calabash fight companion and that is
january 22nd with brian callan crystalia
and christa stefano and myself
for francis ingano and cyril gone
that's it kids we got to put some money
on that uh
can uh oklahoma city bricktown comedy
club december 30th
uh and 31 and january 1st i'll see you
there for new year's let's go salt lake
city wise guys january 6 7 8. that's it
boom i'll be out with brendan all of
january and then uh
february 25th through the
i can't remember those dates i'll be in
kansas city at the comedy club of the
kansas
i always get it we go here we go the
comedy club of kansas city that's pretty
favorite what'd you say pretty up front
pretty up front february 25th and 26th
and then uh merch
you just drop some merch yeah yeah and
then yes i have your merch all right
yeah so
hi kids happy holidays see you wednesday
love you bye